are you fascinated by this and I'm sure  you are about like you look at casamigos  tequila yes look at what the Kardashians  yes all this influence are capital right  celebrity Capital where it's like their  value is In Their audience their name  and what I will tell you is what people  don't know about Ryan Reynolds gin or  the rocks or Clooney's tequila is what a  lot of these celebrities have done  well is they've actually made really  good products somewhere around 20 years  ago people started getting serious and  making like actual good stuff right so  now what I think is fascinating about  that whole genre is they're not mailing  it in on the product and I think it's a  preview of what you're going to see more  and more which is like it's not a  private label that just puts a celebrity  on it which was the whole move of the  80s and 90s people are trying to build  actual things and I do think people like  Mr Beast and others are going to build  multi-billion dollar companies